There is one fundamental issue about calibration and validation, namely that
prediction does not always go hand in hand with understanding.
Look at these two models for the motion of a planet in the solar system.
Let's look at the left model--here the earth is fixed in space
and close to the earth--thus the center of some large circle.
This point moves around that circle and a point on that second circle,
which then moves in this direction.
This is called an epicycle, and we can continue that process.
That point could be the center of another circle and so on and so on until finally
we say that the planet is moving around that final circle.
That's one of the antique models and let's have a look at the right one.
Here the sun is at the center, the earth moves in a circle around the sun,
and that planet moves in circle.
Here comes the last quiz for you--which of these models allows a more flexible calibration
and which of these two models allows a more accurate prediction of the apparent motion
of the planet as seen from earth.